thank you
[Music]
College Park Georgia only 20 minutes
from downtown Atlanta
this suburb is home to the world's
busiest airport and just down the street
from the tarmac is a Smokehouse called
mishans opened in 2002 by the Wilson
family I used to be in in sales but I've
always wanted to own a restaurant
especially a barbecue restaurant so
that's what I decided to do our daughter
is Natalie Michonne and we've decided
that that was a great name for the
restaurant because our passion our goal
was to pass it to Natalie enjoy the
restaurant did great this was my daddy's
baby with Mr Owl being at the top it
made everything work really smoothly
it's out of college right here things
went good you know for a long time here
and unfortunately you know Al had got
sick and we had to have an operation
my dad had my collapsed lung the doctor
told my dad just stay home and take a
break just started hurting a little bit
so I need to really go lay down a lot of
things have gone downhill in the kitchen
since Al has been out
when was the brisket smoked because it's
cold since Mr Owl is sick but Cooks do
what they want to do we're capitalist
[ __ ] yeah whatever dude we're taking
that dog our food is nasty and then when
you go to take it back to get another
plate they'll complain about it or
they'll arguing
and I'll come back here
but if it tastes like [ __ ] don't nobody
want to eat that
the majority of the stuff in here is
already prepped
[Music]
like the Smoked Meats you're reheating
those all the sides are ready all you're
doing is scooping and putting it in a
bowl
is everything okay
the customers are walking out of here
unsatisfied it was slow as hell out here
yes sir but I would love to see is my
daughter run the place but she's just
not doing you know the the job I've
never seen that league in the kitchen
you may see her in passing or maybe
she's hungry can you hand me a spoon a
fork or a spoon please she'll come in
and get us some breakfast or just come
here and rub her stomach
[Music]
Al and I have a certain work ethic
Natalie does not necessarily share that
work ethic
the type of manager that I am I'm more
hands off I'm a little bit more relaxed
when it comes to problems it's too much
wasted energy to be frustrated
I have cameras just spotted around the
restaurant that I can check from my
house and I'm seeing things but not
going like it should be
everyone said their macaroni and cheese
back between the bills the rent and all
the overhead you know we like two
hundred thousand dollars in the hole we
are really at the point not where we
need Chef Ramsey to just help us or it
will be the end of the road
[Music]
before heading to the restaurant Chef
Ramsay has agreed to get together with
mishon's owner Al who requested a
meeting
okay good to meet you yeah same here
um talk to me the restaurant it uh
family around my daughter and and my
wife but uh you know I really want to
retire to be honest with you guys just
need to get my daughter to take over and
run it so the plans
for you to hand the reins over to her
correct because I've been in sort of bad
health I'm sorry to hear that yeah and
it's still giving me some problems and
we mentioned your daughter how old is
she uh she's 32 32. and how capable is
she she has the smarts right just need
to get get it out of right I mean it
sounds like she's been handed this
amazing restaurant on a plate and you're
frustrated that she can't take the reins
and go away and go with it that's it and
when you had the medical problem
obviously you're out the business how
did that run then
not really going it fell apart but I was
watching it the best I could so you're
watching from home yeah I got my little
security cameras I can see from my house
and from the restaurant you watch your
restaurant on a security camera yeah I
got about 18 cameras 18 cameras yeah 18.
I just like to see what they do
hey that's it
well I'm gonna get myself to the
restaurants and I'm gonna have a good
look around okay with my eyes not your
cameras thank you I'll see you back at
the restrooms thank you okay and drive
carefully
[Music]
nice to see you Gordon right hi Natalie
I'm good how are you so um the Michelle
name came from my middle name is
Michelle okay so the Russian has been
named after you right well the decor is
stunning look at this place thank you
um so I'm at your amazing dear husband
earlier they had a quick catch up and he
told me a few things
um I'd love to know from both you um
Your Role is what well I love being
upfront with the customers and your main
role in a day-to-day business the human
resources HR wow so I do payroll and
different things like that so I hide in
the back a lot you hide in the back I
stand a bag I do a lot of the paperwork
and things like that so you're not
really functioning in the restaurant
and according to Al there seems to be
things right now that you could do that
you haven't been doing really when was
the last time you took pressure off him
[Music]
are you always this flat no no I'm just
soaking in how you said I'm not doing
much yeah no I just like my God if that
was my father and mother would give me a
restaurant like that with my neighbor at
the door I don't want to be sleeping
here I would be doing a little bit more
than HR
I'm down to taste the food yeah please
he basically told me that I'm just kind
of like the lazy child with just my name
on a building that pisses me off and I
feel disrespected in my own restaurant
he said you don't do anything here but
payroll no you didn't throw me under the
bus you threw me up under the train
thank you very much you're very welcome
I let you look through the menu and I'm
gonna bring you to just started Wings is
that okay thank you okay
what I'm looking forward to Chef Ramsay
doing is to say things to Natalie that I
would not dare say because we are her
parents it's more than a business
relationship There Is the personal
relationship
hello how are you doing today how are
you I'm doing fine welcome to Michonne's
my name is Tanisha I'll be your server
this evening
my goodness me
[Music]
he ain't never seen a beautiful thick
black girl like me so that's what that
was he liked all these curls and stuff
are you that high maintenance or is it
just a special day today it's a special
day today we don't make hardly any money
here so I don't have to pay this every
week
um you've been here how long I've been
here for two and a half years in your
mind what's wrong what's the biggest
issue here management management wow
that's what does Natalie do
[Music]
um
the truth
what's her role should make sure we get
paid
and that's about it
right okay now Lee she got issues She
lays it I said it that's it is what it
is
okay let's turn off with smoked chicken
gourmet salad okay beef brisket pork
ribs and website cornbread mashed
potatoes and the potato salad as well uh
salad we can't do it because we don't
have it no potato salad no really yeah
the kitchen kitchen they don't like the
peel potatoes
well it's true okay green beans please
and baked beans obviously Black Eyed
Peas okay I didn't hear you sweet potato
souffle yeah
okay collard greens mac and cheese
please I'll go ahead and get your food
yes please oh thank you and that is the
smoked chicken wing
and when were they smoke this morning
they were smoked this morning
enjoy thank you
thank you
[Music]
but me
I'm dry
[Music]
so I'm anxious to know what you thought
yeah do you know what a bit inside it
was dry yeah
we just find out when they were smoked
oh well okay
I was shocked that Chef Ramsay does not
like our smoked wings that just pisses
me off because he's definitely wrong
thank you I'm a shame they were trying
welcome to my shine yeah at least this
should be moisture because it's blue leg
bootleg they just don't care
thank you
wow is this this morning's batch these
are just today's batch it's yesterday's
match
okay Chef I have to eat crow those are
yesterday's Wings time see I knew they
didn't taste fresh and while they served
in yesterday's wings today can I get
today's wings today
anyway just asking
all right are we ready to rock and roll
I'm one big salad and all these sides
okay okay let's go
[Music]
oh yeah lovely thank you
uh God that was quick holy mackerel
there you are thank you very much you're
welcome that's my uh smoked chicken
gourmet salad
um
gross they're rotten tomatoes
[Music]
where's my lovely lady
I'm sorry though the tomatoes they've
got old and sort of yucky and Soggy I
wasn't shocked at all thank you please
have you seen the kitchen yeah they
don't care
um uh
um the tomatoes one of them is old and
the other one it has like a right thing
on it
I don't think it's a problem but really
but I'm not a chef so I don't you know I
don't know I think it's fine but that's
right your name is only on the building
get it right
[Music]
they look drunk
it's dry and chewy but it should sort of
fall off the bone but it's just dry
[Music]
nope
now that's really dry look it's just
like being in the Sahara Desert like a
mouthful of sand it's like sand an hour
at last one
of all this man food damn they mess up
everybody's food
wow it is absolutely shocking all right
here we are why sit down sit down all
right yeah right close your eyes okay
what the hell do not open their eyes I
don't want to eat that our food is nasty
open up
nasty what was that
Black Eyed Peas kill them now yeah they
nasty black-eyed bullets he hid the nail
on the head
we got some problems thank you you're
welcome I need a drink after this
I'm in Georgia right yeah
now I feel like I'm in prisoner huh
that's Dreadful
baked beans
collard greens
wow you're gross way too sweet hideous
beef brisket
is rubbery dry and chewy look at that
you could pass that for beef jerky it's
like a it's like a donchu I don't know
too much about smoking I don't need
nothing about cooking but I know that
ain't right
wow okay can you take me through the
kitchen there's gonna be some [ __ ]
around here Southern brisket like that I
don't know where the [ __ ] start
oh God
sampling the menu that can best be
described as miserable a southern
brisket like that I don't know where the
[ __ ] start Chef Ramsay wants to have
a little chat with the people who are
responsible
where's out Dad yeah come in please so
this is Arch Archie and this is Terence
Terrence yes sir good deceiver and this
is Terrell come over let's talk and see
you and this is Calvin rice oh another
Chef come through Jordan Joe so who's
the head chef
does anyone know I don't do the cooking
no sir not the uh smoke meat
something not quite right here
what'd you do here I'll smoke some meat
was there anything that I tasted today
that was smoked today
uh brisky this piece of [ __ ] here was
smoked today
no not today not today does that look
appetizing
no sir that does not when was that
cooked we'll leave on Saturday on
Saturday
today's Tuesday do you honestly think
that customers would walk through that
door thinking that you're smoking meets
three four days before eating them how
are you eating them the microwavable
microwaving them
it's disgusting for God's sake
is there anything today that I ate that
wasn't microwaved
the sellers
you [ __ ] donut of course you don't
put a [ __ ] higher than it wasn't here
guys I'm not laughing I'm seriously
disappointed
and Natalie you don't need me in here to
tell you that brisket is like dog chew
if my parents named a restaurant after
me I'd make sure that was the [ __ ]
best smoked brisket
my daughter doesn't do what needs to be
done to get this restaurant back in
shape it's just I don't have the words
for it right now
I don't know what to say
I'm lost for words
[Music]
after a lunch that was almost entirely
microwaved Chef Ramsay braces himself
for his first observation of a dinner
service good evening welcome to Michelle
working hard homie
what's that noise in the microwave
[ __ ] out of the microwave what is
that that Seafood
we ripped it that's how they do things
they're just throwing stuff in the
microwave and it's ridiculous
[Music]
ripped it rip tips what's with all the
back stuff they've washing everything
and put it in bags it's just nothingness
you're not even cooking you're just
reheating
where's all this coming from I don't
know that's how we've been reheating it
have you been to another restaurant in
Atlanta have you seen them
you've never been to another kitchen now
it's tearing me up inside of them I've
never seen it like this I mean ever Chef
Ramsey is criticizing every single thing
that we do just because he doesn't like
it doesn't mean that it's wrong show me
the smokers all right please
[Music]
wow look at them I mean do you know what
hurts more than anything the fact that
we we have the most amazing equipment
and yet the product is [ __ ] brisket
turkey chicken smoked in these then we
slice it
bag it chill it then we reheat it in the
microwave does that make sense
please
wow look at that so how long have they
been in how long has it been cooking
so they went in two and a half hours ago
so they're ready for dinner yeah ready
these little tastes now
that's delicious that's what I'm
screaming for they're they're ready
they're delicious we're reheating
yesterday's [ __ ] wings and they're
just immaculate
Natalie don't open the door then
disappear I need to talk to you urgently
so we have Rolls Royce and smokers here
pretty amazing and you got these
that are literally minutes off the
smoker right and yet we can't hold them
and serve that's what we were trying to
figure out it's a no-brainer Nelly
hasn't proven to be able to run this
restaurant so I didn't structure just a
bunch of guys doing their own things
that does not make sense how much those
smokers cost roughly cost
um 17 000 each 17 grand each yeah so
here you are cooking to Perfection and
reheating the food in a 200 microwave
how does that make sense
while the fresh tasty meat from the
smoker gets held for another day
the kitchen sends out plate after plate
of reheated food beef brisket
[Music]
and not surprisingly there is
Disappointment in the dining room let's
try
let's try did that go out
like a dog shot on the side of it I
don't know
yeah they're right tell me the bones dry
guys this bug is supposed to be well
done leave me alone
where's all that going they didn't like
us all right well they just said they
didn't like them Natalie did nothing
this is your business and y'all don't
care
is that normal for so much food to come
back yes yes the whole place is
disorganized it's running with no leader
absolutely right
it was such a disappointment because
Natalie is letting us down she needs to
step up to the plate
as dinner comes to an end
Gordon's inspection of the kitchen is
just beginning what's that in there
chicken is cooked six days ago
yesterday and these ones in here
and these ones in here but if you cook
them yesterday why did they cook them
yesterday look there must be a thousand
Wings there these people don't even
deserve to be running a restaurant let
me tell you
[Music]
see so many wings
piping hot stuck in the refrigeration
unit I suppose it's what you call
winging it
yes there's more
[Music]
that is nasty oh it's like a mass grave
at a dollar 67 a wing
look at that appalled by his discovery
of how much of the food is pre-cooked
look there must be a thousand Wings
there Jeff Ramsay is determined to give
Natalie and her kitchen staff a massive
reality check can you just come in the
kitchen with me please uh all of you
thank you
let's go let's go
wow
kidding me oh my god wow oh my God why
do you have 100 smoked wings like you
can't be for real
I am absolutely mortified
what the hell is going on
we served a hundred customers and we're
carrying all this food until tomorrow
or the next day or who knows and we have
a smoker in there full of fresh wings
and I could have cried to think that
this was a set of first before the fresh
ones I've never seen a more fragmented
disorganized setup I've never ever seen
anything like this
just looking at that food on the counter
like that I'm like wow really really
shocking you know I look at it like you
know that could be going in my pocket as
far as you know as a raise or whatever
you've got the most equipped kitchen
ever
stunning dining room and look at the
amount of staff in here but all the
advantages can't fix the mentality of
how we're working with our head up our
ass rudderless
the biggest problem the system tell me
about it
and you accept it because you send it
you confirm that's good enough
you have your name
in lights and you can sit there and
depend on your parents for another 30
years someone's gonna have to step up
if these are what we cook this evening
at the end of the evening do we throw
them away
it's easy how many how many customers do
we have tonight a hundred how many
portions of wings do we sell
roughly 25 yep
that stops there
I don't need to tell you that
I just think you're in denial
no I'm not in denial I'm I'm learning
pretending by learning needs getting
involved taking responsibility all right
can I have a word with you please
everybody else just stay here count the
[ __ ] wings I had no clue Chef Ramsay
would be this critical Chef Ramsay does
not understand a lot of the ways we do
things here he was overboard
You've Got Your Name In Lights this
question is named after you tell me
one-to-one why you haven't stepped up
just because you don't I'm not gonna sit
up here and holler and spring holla and
you know what I wouldn't walk around
like little miss perfect and I don't yes
you do no I don't yes you do no I don't
yes you do the biggest problem is you've
never heard it enough okay
being brought into this world in the
Silver Spoon you can't sponge you have
to get off your ass and do something
about it what we're going to look at
your father get mum to step up honestly
hand the reins over and let's get
somebody else in here if you are not
going to step up to the plate I'm not
just
walking in here every day not doing
anything oh
smoker
questioned on a plate a stunning
restaurant and you don't seem to bother
I'm very bothered
you blow smoke up my ass how dare you
I'm the haidar manager I haven't had you
fired in two minutes
the bottom line is you don't want it
joke you're right
it is clear that Natalie's lack of
leadership has resulted in a frustrated
and ineffective staff
to get through to her Gordon has asked
the family to stay in the office so they
can observe a staff meeting by way of
the surveillance cameras that was a
crazy 24 hours right yes
so for me I want to find out what the
issues are
a leader
in the kitchen who does the time you do
your own yeah what to save the
frustration
when we come and I ask you where you
want to
seriously
so do they keep switching people around
if we know Keno is the strongest in the
middle why on Fridays and Saturday night
Kino is in the damn back prepping food
it makes no sense we're going to suffer
why is that if you're not gonna work
where we need you how are we going to
get stuff
it's not consistent this is my thing to
y'all we get well we don't have this
once we've gotten to a table and run the
table in oh didn't we tell y'all we
don't have it that is not the most
[Music]
and when you find out everything's just
run down dwindled pretty much everybody
just do what they're going to do
everybody's going at each other because
it's just you know no one running things
so everything is just hostile
if we had
this place I honestly believe would be
like night and day but we need that
direction are we not gaining direction
from Natalie
oh no Natalie doesn't step up to the
plate as she should it's so aggravating
this is your establishment I mean come
on
football bottom line the ship ain't
gonna move without a captain got to have
some leadership Gary it's so frustrating
no one's no one's got the reins and it's
heading for disaster
[Music]
okay it's gonna be two seconds please
yeah it was painful to see and hear a
lot of that conversation I feel like a
lot of the blame came on me today and it
hurts it's a cry for help there
in otherwise none of you'd be here they
are begging for guidance for a leader
for a captain for a Guiding Light an
inspiration that's here you know 10 12
hours a day and this finding that
structure right you know this is serious
Natalie do you think you are ready to
step up and grab the ball by the hordes
and shape this place
[Music]
I know I'm ready to step up
do you want to I want to
come with me two seconds come up
yeah come over
please
I want to hear from you
telling your parents yeah how much you
want this and what it means to you
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's nobody else but you
and you said you can either
run the business and take it on
or you can decide to sell it I wanted to
make sure that my dad's Vision in my
head's Dream came true and I'm gonna
work hard to make sure that's what it is
and I I want you to trust me guess
are you happy with us happy when I'm
looking for a big hug
it was really amazing here I'm telling
me and my wife that she can do it now
she'll refocus herself to to really get
the business and keep it going if you
ever
ever gonna let go Now's the Time
the chance is a very important Legacy to
my father this is his whole life so I'm
here for him
[Music]
now that Natalie has expressed her
commitment to do what it takes to leave
the restaurant and I'm ready to step up
and I want you to trust me Chef Ramsay
is committed to her Festival I was very
touched watching you step up and telling
your parents how much you want this do
you know what
I believe you I'm by your side now 110
don't be scared to make mistakes don't
worry about that okay yeah I've made
thousands
Chef Ramsay has opened my eyes to a lot
at first I was kind of skeptical I was
kind of hurt but I trust his judgment
now I've got something very important to
discuss with you I want you to nominate
someone that's going to step up and
become your head cook someone that men's
a smoker that coordinates the purchasing
that controls everything running through
your mind now let's go in the kitchen
the kitchen lacks a leader and that's
where I need to start first all right
guys this is two seconds please
Natalie wants a quick word with you all
right gentlemen so this is going to be
some new Waters right now for all of us
Terence you've been here for years
you've always had your heart in the
right place from here on out I want you
to be the head over this kitchen okay
for another to make me a leader in this
kitchen I'm very excited about it I'm
ready for the challenge let's get this
team rolling and make sure that we have
put forth a hundred percent got it it
felt great to take the Rings this is the
way it's supposed to be I finally have a
sense of where I need to go to move this
restaurant forward you've got the badge
now step up to the plate that's just it
yeah yep
[Music]
that the restaurant's leadership is in
place Chef Ramsay has an important
transformation of his own to present to
the staff good morning
good
it's time to show you a menu deserving
of his beautiful restaurants ready yeah
yeah come over to the bar please
oh goodness wow
darling please take one and pass them
along new menu it's easy to read this is
a lovely straightforward stunning menu
and more importantly
there's not a restaurant anywhere and
100 mile radius that has spent the money
you spent on those smokers those smokers
is equivalent to having four other
members of full-time staff in your
kitchen you just wasn't using it
properly
so with the way we've Incorporated it is
the backbone of the menu
okay let's start off at the top here
a pulled pork sandwich done with
delicious corn puree running through the
middle
oh yes absolutely amazing next to that
we've got the most amazing beef brisket
a stunning half chicken delicious smoked
chicken wings look at the size of them
do we need to serve any more than that
than a portion I'm gonna go to the
sauces every table has those amazing
sauces it's beautiful it's it's the look
that I want put out there I feel great
yeah I'm so happy I have a special gift
for you because
you are now running this place I'd like
to introduce you to someone very special
Chef Adam good morning how are you great
how are you good to see you this young
man he's an expert in barbecue he's been
trained under Tom colicchio I've
arranged for him to be with you for the
next month great what do you think the
smoke is about there you're brilliant
I'm very excited so a Guiding Light a
huge support and you if you don't pick
up on this and stay close to this guy
for the next month don't worry about
that you're crazy
chef Adam is a lifesaver and I don't
even think he realizes how much you know
I love him already okay but thank you
thank you see you shortly yes nice to
meet you I'm ready to eat food and I'm
ready
oh wow yes
it was absolutely delicious I am past
excited about selling Fresh Products I
think I could do a cartwheel in the
dining room if they're wearing so many
tables in here you know your rib is good
but you can use your fork to break it
apart everything tastes so good oh my
God I need a plate I'm very proud to
sell this food I hope that this new menu
is symbolic of change to show that we'll
just keep rising to the top now who
gonna wheel me out of here that's what I
want to know
with the relaunch approaching Terence
gears up for his new role as head chef
chef you know you ready to roll got
McCain face on boss and Natalie with the
support of her new consultant Adam
Embraces her new role as leader if
there's ever time to make your market
tonight right hold the ratings and let
them know that you're the boss okay
let's go baby I'm ready let's go I'm
very anxious to show Chef Ramsay that I
can do this I can beat the machine of
machines
[Music]
as the doors open for me Sean's relaunch
diners are lined up around the block
eager to try the new menu yeah it's
going to be pretty full so as soon as
you can get here and to help generate
even more positive Buzz Chef Ramsay has
invited a group of the city's most
influential barbecue experts this big
table here are very very important and
they have a festival it has 15 000 turn
out this is it this first impression is
going to be this Lasting Impression we
need to do well hello my name is
mashonda I'm one of the owners here and
I just wanted to personally thank you
for coming because I hear that you guys
are barbecue folks too
and the fried pickles all right the
catfish nuggets
here we go who's pulling out talk to
each other guys I need a smoke chicken
sandwich got your small chicken sandwich
I need a catfish nugget please with
Natalie feeling confident that the
kitchen is in good shape in terence's
hands see I'll be back in five minutes
yeah I've got it boss I got it she heads
to the dining room to check in on the
customers if you've been here before you
noticed we made several changes and so I
was walking through the restaurant I was
pumped all of our meats here that we
smoke on premise our meat is very tender
so I felt good I was doing my job well
and everything was great okay but
minutes later back in the kitchen the
cooks are having a hard time adapting to
the new menu where's Brad I need fries
and are having problems finding a rhythm
hey guys we should be waiting for fries
food is hanging too long I've got
entrees there entrees there she's just
stopped I'm starving it's been like 28
minutes
they wait 30 minutes for their Fried
Chicken oh no no no come on I need
coleslaw talk to me three BJ's I need
them down please
because everyone knows that this food is
behind
complaints about long ticket time so now
everybody's morale is just like Fair we
need to overview off the same page guys
we've got ourselves in a situation
customers are complaining I don't want
one more dish in that window until we
get this board clear how are we going to
turn this around this is a [ __ ]
nightmare
it's 45 minutes into mishan's relaunch
we're getting complaints about long
ticket time and although the cooks are
pushing food out they are not completing
an order and as a result food is sitting
at the pass I don't want one more dish
in that window until we get this poor
clear and customers are sitting hungry
including the VIPs so they're getting
backed up in the kitchen okay they're
panicking and all they're doing is
they're putting their food up in the
window one plate on top of another plate
food's drying out okay so they have to
take a breather clear the board and
start again okay Chef Ramsay pulling me
to the side helped me know that it's my
job to jump in the kitchen and make sure
that the cooks are actually listening I
need a fried catfish and I need that
fish fillet like yesterday
I need you to listen to me yes I need to
make sure if it's not starting another
ticket okay until we go ahead and clear
Claude I really need to make sure that
you're focusing and making sure that
you're not just putting plates up all
right y'all let's roll yes ma'am let's
start got a lot of stuff holding up here
I need three Wings on the Fly and I'd
really got to get the burger because
that's holding up the window yes keep it
going yeah
I was frustrated because I still got
food in the window waiting on the fried
catfish guys but Nelly's made me settle
down
the skies are not falling let's just
focus breathe and
come on
we paid for how long my black is Snapper
black and Snapper working hard Chef well
Natalie has helped her kitchen navigate
their way back on course keep on talking
guys let's go she has also come up with
an idea on how to entertain her special
guest
um I would like to show you our smokers
we had some hiccups so I took the
barbecue festival guys to go out and
look at the smokers
these are our babies right here these
are about four years old each smoker
holds 700 pounds yes you can they were
just so excited I like to see in
people's face light up we'll have wings
on four or five racks at a time
we're supposed to cook time the brisket
is about 12 to 14 hours depending on the
weight okay I think I did pretty good
tonight that's more expensive thank you
very much thank you thank you Natalie's
quick thinking is not only delighted the
barbecue experts
macaroni and cheese in a souffle I can
go right here it has also bought the
kitchen the time they needed to catch up
make the nuggets
boy all right y'all how we doing you're
good you know how we doing beautiful
okay Natalie helped us get back on track
very vocal very visual communicating
with us is this coming out now this is
complete then take it well Natalie has
impressed her staff
the menu is a big hit with diners
I'm amazed seeing customers with smiles
on their face we haven't had that in
ever years those are some of the best
ribs wow that's great I'm so happy it
was Natalie's night tonight I think she
did a great job bye thank you so much
thank you
you bought your butts off for me the big
difference was the way that you still
under immense pressure worked together
give yourselves around the pools come on
come on okay
and you know what you have an exciting
Dynamic owner tonight you would test it
and you did a terrific job let me tell
you
thank you thank you so much and uh he
wasn't here this evening God bless him
he's probably watching from his bed
okay but you did him proud let me tell
you Chef Ramsay has been a real
influence on Napoli and now that Natalie
is in charge the future for machans is
very bright right well done all of you
well done
thank you I'm glad that Chef Ramsay came
down to give me a swift kick
to show me that I can do it and help me
show my parents that I can do it
take care
[Music]
I didn't realize when almady's played
that he'd be too ill to be with us here
for relaunch tonight but this restaurant
led by his daughter now and her little
staff made a major transformation
tonight my hope is now that he gets well
and has the pleasure of seeing his baby
becoming a big success
wow how ironic two miles from the
airport and you finally earned your
wings good night Georgia
after Chef Ramsay left Natalie showed
she is more committed than ever to
carrying on her father's Legacy
and with Chef Adams training Terence is
in complete control of the kitchen
[Music]
as for Al he now has what he always
wanted a successful restaurant run by
the one person he built it for his
daughter Natalie